bella tutti ragazzi che lo vede che sono
video sono fa vj e oggi siamo
sull'episodio finale di metz al desco in
tutto questo non ho capito bene dove
dovrei andare visto che nel corridoio mi
mangiano la faccia però vabbè poi non ho
capito sono fiction i topi dai malware
cosa fare paga difficilissimo non
capisco sono stato attaccato dai topi
manco questi avesse dottorati mio padre
maya presta porta let's go
anche il tipo di prima la tipa o il tipo
è una tipa porca vacca rete è stata
dall'ato ridarmi il profumo di mamma
cosa c'è che non va con lei è che posso
dire è morta è morta quello non va
vabbè io vorrei trovare il profumo di
mamma visto che lascia un oggetto
potrebbe essere quello c'è un crack nel
muro rotto il muro
eccolo ecco è questo il profumo di mamma
perfetto c'è il culo trovato subito tra
tutti i baby hare hare aveva accelerato
c'è un tipo che li mangia la faccia va
bene non ho io non ho neanche
controllato bene la stanza ci sono
entrato lì a prendere subito il culo
assurdo visto che lascia il demonio cosa
che faccio le profumi di barba
esattamente benedetto solo un po ok
mamma permetto solo un po
ok a posto c'è una macchia di sangue io
adesso col profumo magari manda via il
sofi perché il tumore che belli che
corrono con me ecco le suore e
ultimamente negli horror non mi stanno
piacendo quindi non ci basta voglia di
parlarti infatti lasciamo perdere
no il corpo mi serve e aperto grazie
[Musica]
qualcuno sta arrivando a gesù cristo di
dio va bene è arrivato il demonio
ora che a macchia che brutta rocco
faccio la mia che ansia di vivere lo
picchiamo travail riposati nelle e ben
non vedo alternative in questo momento
quindi si riposati nelle va bene c'è un
demonio fuori dalla mia porta ma io
dormo chissenefrega
va bene e questo è quello che io penso
in genere quando mi sto per addormentare
a meno che il letto non si sposti da
solo quello è un altro discorso
entrare dentro il buco dentro nell'altro
cella su good quindi lui lei pensa che
io sia qui in realtà sono qua quindi
appena si distanzia un attimo io corro
con un puledro veloce mi sarebbe stata
vai vai vai pero muoviti più ad una
porta ci credo mai ce l'ho fatta non ci
credo ma il corvo è volato via via via
che gli dà forza 6 lista e le bon ha
molto meno è una bambola carina è un
sacco di capelli per essere una bambola
cosa facciamo le tagliamo i capelli non
l'italiano i capelli posso entrare
adesso perché non lo sapevi dall'inizio
e vuoi ancora aiutarlo non lo so non lo
so che cosa dovrei fare
ma devo andare
papà è tutto ciò che o qualsiasi cosa
succeda io supporterò papa è ciò che ho
promesso la mamma che ragazzina le
persone non cambiano così facilmente ma
c'è una bambola dietro la statua infatti
non capivo che mi stesse parlando c'è un
portale questo ti porterà all altro
mondo
di certo non mi porta al carrefour
nichelato ovunque io non ho ancora
capito chi sia veramente andare che
cos'è questo mister e acqua magica ecco
infatti non metterla su capelli un
prodotto della mia compagna non metterla
sui cervelli acqua gi.ca per favore
porta l'ha con te posso salvare papa con
questa l'acqua il potere di esorcizzare
le maledizioni
allora io salverei la partita e andrei
in bocca la tassa ton al demanio ne
andiamo quest area salta altro mondo
oscurità
la madonna mia madre con mio padre
quindi sei venuta ai ma non ci credo e
mia madre la riconosco dagli occhi che
non ha quindi non è sono gli occhi che
mi fanno pensare alla mamma sei
veramente tu mamma mamma l'hai visto
nella strada che il percorso fino a qui
non è vero hai a le atrocità che
quest'uomo continua a commettere e non
voglio che ci siano altre vittime non
vuoi la stessa cosa ai a tu menti ha
tratto c'è anche maria lia destra la
vista
ciò che mi rende felice essere conte
papa quindi non lasciarmi da solo
nessuno deve interferire con una voce
molto demoniaca credo visto che è
scritto in maiuscolo o di roma è sempre
una citazione al signore degli anelli
regala lo giuro mamma no tesoro
lasciarci andare
e niente ahia ahia nel senso che sta
attirando forte papà
l'ho salvato ma dai ma fortissima papa
perché non ascolti tua madre non portare
via papa via dalla mia vista cioè della
mia strada era da brava mamma
nessuno può averlo mamma fermati lui è
mio
[Musica]
a cosa serve questo mister e acqua
magica un prodotto della mia compagnia
il potere dell'acqua gerit ora
sicuramente posso salvare papa con
questo papa se il tuo amore la raggiunge
sono sicuro che anche tua mamma possa
essere salvata davvero non ne sono molto
sicura questo dovrei fare salvo papa dio
perché mi dà questa scelta
no dai non posso perché sono arrivato
fin qua per papa però la mamma sembra
più io non lo so non so se il padre
porca vacca
mi dispiace per quello che vedrete nel
video e nell'altro però vale salverò
papa brucia brucia maglia che cosa fai
mi dispiace mamma
honda energe sto scomparendo
il mio corpo sta scomparendo amma ayane
senza te le fa malissimo dove sono papà
che io ho salvato mio padre veramente
papa sono stato salvato aia voglio che
tu non sappia la verità ma con ciò che
mi è rimasto dei miei poteri flashback
cosa dio
le scene quelle toccanti dove si toccano
dottore la signora non sa della nostra
relazione che cosa importa
non credo che si fidi di me penso sia
questo il problema la ragazzina sarà
avrà 11 anni molto presto l unità
problematica sicuramente sì gentile con
lei per favore
lei è il mio più prezioso la mia più
preziosa bambola di tutte una bambola io
oggi ho scoperto che in realtà non mi
voleva solo come bambola mamma passa
tutto il tempo qui sotto nella cantina
non dirmi che ancora con quella ragazza
voglio fargli trasformarla nella mia
bambola più bella quando posso cosa sarà
il capolavoro tra tutte le bambole che
ho fatto
c'è lui faceva il bambole con i morti
questo faceva per quale ammazza tanta
gente asfor male in una bambola ma amava
che succede alla fine si scopre che non
lo sbagliato salvarmi ho fatto la voglio
trasformare in una bambola ok
non ci credo non ti lascerò non lascerò
che tu lo faccia me ne vado
what cosa è successo presentando di
ucciderla ma no l'ha uccisa
maledizione
ma no
[Musica]
scusami ma se è andata veramente così
perché volevi ancora perché eri ancora
innamorata di tuo marito passa che mi
dicesse no lui fa cose cattive e io ti
avrei salvata invece non hanno mai detto
quello hai detto che volevi tutto per te
milady milanista alla fine barriera
buona dottore perchè l'hai fatto
doveva essere fatto per il futuro di aia
scappa scappa via da lui aia sì ma non
adesso non farla spaventata fai finta di
essere presa bene poi scappino aia cosa
c'è che non va perché sia perché così
paura di tuo padre
no non ci credo regala ecco quello che
ho visto era la verità papà tu molto
bene beh baia non pensi che tua mamma
sia bellissima dimmi che cosa che cosa
vorrei indossare la farò scappa scappa
scappa dove stai andando vieni vieni a
fianco di tuo padre
no hai iniziato ad odiarmi mi dispiace
ma non voglio diventare una bambola
scappa stava bene e non avevo scelto
questo finale dove scelto l'altro e non
so come finirà adesso però vabbè teschio
aprire la porta agli altri sta
difendendo le bambole il manichino l'ha
bloccata grazie ai a scappa scappa
scappa
apriti quindi mi stanno difendendo le
bambole spezzate
ragazzi è orribile e come faccio a porta
sforzo con lemonia sta sfondando con la
motosega aiuta video o mio dio apre non
apre
ok si sa bene si è aperta la sua festa
porta quanto tempo devo correre ma dai
ed allora che proprio ok veloce che
brutta roba da mio padre lo schivarlo
fortissimi come lo schifo lo schifo
[Musica]
punti l'arena tutti nata straniero come
dietro non posso andare di là pacchetto
veloce ce l'ha fatta ce l'ha fatta
cercata ma vai vai
mamma mia maria non lasciare che gli
scappi da maria kagami brava maria
aspetta no mariano di vista la mia parte
maria cosa faccio
brava scappa scappa smettila è corrotto
[Musica]
la libreria libri esposta e shining
quanti riferimenti ai film non mi hai
fatto perdere un po ridere scappa la
morte perché sono sempre chiuse le porte
aperte cosa chi è questa vieni con noi
no perché potete attaccare lui invece
che me lasciami andare io mi voglio è
sceso non voglio farti remare a ya no
fermati papà papà ed aia saranno sempre
insieme adesso quindi riposa in pace
ti voglio bene ma muoviti muoviti
[Musica]
grazie a dio messo nata la sveglia
misurava svegliato potevo rimanere così
per sei anni
what che finale ditta non è vero che io
ho proprio sbagliato a salvare meglio
allora cioè io sono sfigato perché trovo
sempre finale peggiore non sempre ero
sempre trovato il peggiore la cosa che
ti sembra più brutta da fare non la fai
mai scegli sempre la cosa migliore no
quindi tutti avrebbero lasciato morire
il padre dopo quello che ha fatto e poi
alla fine si scopre che in realtà la
scelta che ti sembrava peggiore nella
terra quella migliore da fare sempre
così quando c'è un bivio no quindi non
avrei mai salvato il padre o risalvato
mia madre sempre
e invece no avrei dovuto per salvare mia
madre salvare il padre della scelta
peggiore e si è confermato
effettivamente lasciata peggiore
orribile
se volete vedervi l'altro finale mi
scuso tantissimo se mi vedrete
imponibile nel modo in cui parlo nel
modo in cui sono la qualità del video
eccetera
però trovate l'altro finale in
descrizione che lo lascio magari con i
ragazzi questa la manpower stato bello
rigiocarlo un po meno il finale però che
la vita vi sia piaciuto spero che la
serie vi sia piaciuta come al solito
servito è piaciuto lasciare un commento
non mi piace anche ora è stato
recapitato una descrizione se non saremo
rischiate vi e non ci vediamo da belle
ragazze
[Musica]